for the first time ever a brother and
sister will both battle for a spot in
the World Chess Championship earlier
this year pragna anant rames Babu had an
incredible performance in the World Cup
making it all the way to the finals to
face the great Magnus Carlson his second
place finish earned him a spot in the
candidates where the next World
Championship Challenger will be
determined just recently his sister Vali
rames Babu went undefeated in the
women's Grand Swiss this impressive
performance also won her a spot in the
upcoming women's candidates tournament
the prime minister of India
congratulated both players on their
incredible achievements the siblings are
also both ranked 14th in the world a
coincidence or a good omen only time
will tell but one thing's for sure chess
runs in this family